vous avez toujours été très attiré par
la religion juive bien que n'étant pas
juive puisque votre mère ne l'est pas
mais j'étais toujours trouvé très
attirés oui j main
j'ai eu une attirance l'âge où ça arrive
genre à l'adolescente
serge gainsbourg lui croyant rien et
c'était rien je sais pas en effet de
juger des faits tout ce qui est
tradition non moi j'ai pas ouais de la
sacem quand même ça me rend de fait vous
avez pas souffert de ma mère est une
actrice où mon père est un chanteur
n'avait pas souffert de ça je crois pas
je crois que je me suis même pas posé la
question c'était comme ça et non je
crois pas donc sous le seul nom vous
avez un petit peu souffert c'est quand
ils sont séparés c'est tout ouais comme
pour tout pour tous les enfants
non mais c'est pas parce que vous avez
un peu les mêmes souvenirs que romane
bohringer c'est à dire que l son père
l'emmenait comme ça dans les dents les
boîtes de nuit à l'âge de notre patte de
xambes enfin des gens l'âge de 5-6 ans
et vous paraît ya deux ans vous étiez
dans les bois vous endormir sur les
banquettes s'est bien passé de regarder
a mentionné un très bon pire on avait
une vie à la fois très stable et est un
peu folle parce qu'on est suivi ouais
alors je vous êtes sur un plateau c'est
le plateau de la pirate qui est réalisé
par votre beau père jacques doillon et
jane birkin dit qu'à ce moment là vous
avez porté sur l'actrice laure marsac un
regard de jalousie est-ce que c'était
une envie d'être actrice
ou est-ce que c'était au contraire
simplement parce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse attention à vous je crois pas je
crois que je crois que c'était pas un
réel désir de d'être actrice ou de jouer
quoi que ce soit c'est étant enfant vous
aviez pas spécialement le le désir de
faire comme votre mère non je crois pas
vous avez commencé d'une façon très très
marrante un jour jane birkin se s'en va
et laisse un petit mot sur la table elie
chouraqui cherche une ado de tournage
vas-y pourvoir vous y allez vous êtes
choisis c'est génial
ces paroles et musiques oui j'ai jamais
pris de cours non j'aurais aimé je suis
sûr que j'aurais pris du plaisir à le
faire mais j'ai pas osé et après paroles
et musique vous avez voulu partir en
suisse dans une pension alors que
finalement votre mère et kate vous
disais cette détestable il va pas assez
insupportable et pensions vous êtes
parti un an dans une pension en suisse
et vous avez assez bien vécu moi j'ai
très bien vécu je pense que j'avais
envie d'un truc rigoureux
vous aviez besoin d'autorité y avait
passé la maison
s'il y en avait mais j'avais envie de ça
tu avais envie de passer par les mêmes
choses qu'eux
mr que ma soeur et et de contraindre
moi-même ah ouais j'ai besoin de
discipline alors serge gainsbourg disait
en parlant de vous charlotte est une
orchidée déguisé en orties de moins en
moins de moins en moins orties de plus
en plus orchidées c'est vrai qu'avant
vous étiez d'une timidité maladive à
vous avez l'air beaucoup mieux quand
même ça s'est arrangé
bon si vous vous réfugiez un peu dans le
silence avant vous étiez un peu angoissé
non pas angoissé j'étais très très
timide
ouais je ne faisaient pas d'efforts pour
montrer contre on va voir l'époque
comment c'était magnéto serge la
gagnante et charlotte gainsbourg
merci
merci que
je remercie club de m'avoir fait pour me
voir laisser faire ce film
claude miller a remercié claude muller
savent bien ce jour
césar en 86
quand tu nous tiens un peu comme sa tête
dans les épaules et tous là vous êtes un
peu plus j'étais jamais très très jeune
au décollage la 4 14 ouais c'est ça à
l'époque vous disiez souvent je suis pas
une vraie actrice comme ça si ça
marchait pas vous auriez pu dire c'est
fait c'était pas mon truc c'est ça ouais
maintenant ça y est vous avez bon c'est
pas on sait jamais avec ce métier ça
peut s'arrêter
ouais à chaque film j'ai toujours envie
de tout arrêter ou non non c'est à
chaque team où j'ai l'impression de tout
recommencer
bah vous essayez de vous arrêter puis
comme je sais pas quoi faire d'autre
pour commencer alors ils vont vous a
décoincé qu'en maintenant pour la prépa
de ce film je parle et vous à vous a
fait dire le texte à haute voix il vous
a oui on a eu des séances de travail
très très intenses
drôle maintenant quand j'y repense mais
difficile difficile mais il me poussait
il essayait de il voulait que je me sens
clip sur le tournage donc il voulait
glace j'avais trop loin peut-être en
préparant et de que jose mais c'était
même dur devant lui devais faire des
choix
surtout que c'était dans un petit bureau
chez pathé rude pour la première -et non
complet s'était pas non plus chez vous à
la maison
il voulait que vous soyez un personnage
heureux bien dans sa peau c'est vrai que
dans le film d'ailleurs vous est
vachement légère quoi oui oui il voulait
que je sois que je sois ouverte que je
sois gay ça ça vous a aidé est ce que
votre psychanalyste vous a aidé aussi
avoue décoincer sûrement ouais c'est
fini maintenant vous avez fini de gagner
je sais pas j'ai jamais fait moi
j'aimerais savoir comment ça se passe
non si jamais fini je pense qu enfin
c'est fini mais faire tomber sur leur
accent sur vous a fait progresser sa
masse hama
ça m'a permis de fin je sais comment
faire
j'ai des solutions vous savez où il faut
aller chercher la solution maintenant
oui ça veut pas dire que j'y fais mais
je sais que jamais en rapport avec votre
image ou simplement vous y pense et plus
je m'en fous enfin je sais pas si je
m'en fous je fais un tout petit peu plus
détendu c'est moins grave car oui
d'accord mais ça va mieux
c'est vrai que est enfant vous ressenti
un petit peu être vilain petit canard de
la famille vous dit j'étais entouré de
deux de jane de quais de lou doillon de
bambou et vous étiez un peu malheureuse
complexe et aux malheureuses pas
malheureuse complexe et j'étais très
complexée ouais parce que je pense que
dans ma famille la beauté c'était
quelque chose
ouais c'était important blaye et des
scènes dans lequel vous vous êtes
parfait vous savez la mema soignants
c'est bien occuper de vous et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux